What a week it has been in the United
States, and I'm going to try to put together
some overarching thoughts about what we've seen
in the country over the last week and by what
we've seen. I, of course, am talking about what
is really a predictable and logical culmination
of the most depraved and disgusting
presidential term that we have ever seen.
I mean, Donald Trump inciting a riotous
insurrection in Washington, D.C., when he simply
could not admit that he simply lost to Joe Biden.
He wishes he could have won, but he didn't and
unable to do that. It led to what we saw last week
and causing that to splinter the Republican Party,
part of which has immediately abandoned
Donald Trump, far too late to actually
deserve any rehabilitation of their reputation.
But it is merely a move for self-preservation,
part of which that Republican Party
continues to defend Donald Trump
while the country fights a global hundred year
pandemic that has been completely mishandled
and seems unable to get the mass vaccination
program growing. So going. So that's that's like
the big picture. And we have to be able to say
something overarching about what's going on here.
And there are a few lessons in the midst of the
chaos. But the most important thing we can do
is to not understate the importance of this
moment as an inflection point in the path of
the United States of America. And, you know, it's
impossible to include everything that's happened.
And I know that many of us are still sort of
struggling to figure out all of the answers about
what happened. And there are so many details,
different people finding more interesting or
less interesting and focusing on. But there will
be continued time for that. I think understanding
the big picture here and the importance of
this moment is the best thing that we can do.
And it really goes back to 2016 when we
had tons of Republicans, most of the right
saying we like Trump, much of the right saying,
well, we don't love Trump, but we still think
he's way better than Hillary. And we also had too
many of our fellow leftists saying Trump wouldn't
be that bad or he might even be sort of like
Hillary I don't like either, so I won't vote.
They're both corporate shills. I don't see
any practical difference between the two
or let's mix it up by putting in Trump. It'll be
wacky and it'll get us a real progressive in 2020.
O The Supreme Court's not that important. You
remember that stuff. Those people were all wrong.
The ones on the right were obviously wrong and the
ones on the left were obviously wrong as well. Now
we don't need apologies. Let's just recognize that
they were wrong. The people on the left who were
sounding the alarm as we saw Trump's authoritarian
tendencies and immediately we saw them before and
immediately after getting elected. And some of
us were called hyperbolic and overexaggerated. If
anything, we understated the risk. Every worst and
instinct of Donald Trump has become the nightmare
scenario, and it culminated last week and it might
not even be the culmination. We'll talk about what
the next week and a half is going to look like.
And it looks like it will be utterly insane.
I'll tell you what Donald Trump has planned.
There will be more armed riots, I am sure of it.
How successful they are remains to be seen. So
this is all to say, let's not sell short the
importance of this moment. And there are two ways
that this moment could go. Big picture. One way
is very straightforward. We all decide that this
can never happen again and that putting politics
aside, putting aside your view of like tax rates,
putting aside your view of business regulation, we
decide as a country that what happened last week
is an existential threat to the United States.
We recognize that Joe Biden will be president
and that we have to go back to drawing a line
in the sand and saying all of this from the last
four years is over the line of what is acceptable,
period, no matter what your view is on taxation.
Right. And part of this is, I have to say,
not tolerating Trumpy and insanity. It's not valid
politics. It's not valid activism. It's not valid
participation in the political system. And it
has to be stopped. Now, you will hear some say
if we don't tolerate tolerate other points of view
than we are as bad as them. And that's ridiculous.
Some are saying this in terms of Trump's permanent
Twitter ban, which I'm going to talk about later.
It's just other opinions and we must be tolerant.
It's the wrong perspective. We tolerate other
opinions. Yes, an armed insurrection of the
capital is not an opinion. It's a criminal
travesty. It's anti-American, it's
anti-democratic. And when you tolerate
everything, eventually the truly intolerant
come to power and destroy society. And the
very tolerance you want doesn't exist anymore.
And it is you who who who is being silenced.
This is where principals stop being valuable in
the abstract, yes, we are a nation of tolerance.
We tolerate other types of people. We tolerate
other religions or no religion whatsoever. We
tolerate ideology. We tolerate political ideas and
dissent and adversarial media. Yes, all of it. We
tolerate all of it. But you have to know how far
that goes. And what we're seeing doesn't have to
be tolerated. And it shouldn't be understand that
if we tolerate what we've seen over the last week,
there will simply be more and more of it until
they are in power and are completely intolerant.
Toleration doesn't fix it. Toleration doesn't
change minds. So one option is that, as I said,
we as a country come together against what we're
seeing. We recognize that the country ceases
to be a country if this scofflaw criminality and
revisionist history and unhinged authoritarianism
is tolerated. And that's going to be tough for
some people. I'm with you. If you are a moderate
Republican, if you're in the vein of John McCain,
for example, it's going to be really tough to say,
wow, I'm a Republican, but that was bad. And it's
it's unmitigated. There's no ifs, ands or buts.
It was a mistake we lost. And now we have to
eliminate this malignancy. And Joe Biden is going
to be president for a while. Democrats will have
the House and Senate for a while. That's tough to
accept, even if you've been disgusted by Trump as
a Republican. So to those folks, yes, we need to
be tolerant and accept them, but we do not need
to tolerate what led to the armed mob last week.
There's no planet on which that can be tolerated.
We really are on a precipice. Does this escalate
even supposedly with more planned planned
riotous mobs in the next ten days, or do we
actually come together? And I mean the left and
the center and the sane right and law enforcement
and our sane elected officials, the ones that
are left and say this can never happen again
and to stop that and it's going to take years
to fix. But do we start today or do we let them
get away with any aspect of it on the legal?
We must take swift legal action against Trump
and the terrorists and every state and
local Republican member who supported this.
That's the best way to put a stop to this
movement. There have to be consequences.
And one of the things I'm sadly seeing are
reactions from some of these right wingers
saying you left, David, it sounds like you
hate the country. Why not leave or whatever?
No, no, no, no. I'm an immigrant to this country
and I'm incredibly grateful to this country.
I want more people to get what I've gotten from
this country. And Trump is the opposite of that.
If we allow what happened last week to grow
and to fester, we go the opposite of what the
United States should be. And I know that this
has been said so many times. It's not patriotic
to just stand by a politician just because
their president we talked about this when the
right tried to say you're not patriotic if you
don't support George W. Bush's war in Iraq. No,
no, no, no. That war was bad for the country.
And so it's patriotic to stand by what's best
for the country. And I've warned against defying
politicians by both the left and the right.
It is patriotic to stand up for what's best
for the country, even if it conflicts with
your partizanship. So do not understate the
importance of this moment. And we're going to
talk more about that as we get closer and closer
to the inauguration of Joe Biden as president,